As I mentioned,
you will need to define the design
challenge before the design sprint.
To help you decide on
the design challenge,
here's some things that you can do.
First, you should
interview key stakeholders.
Stakeholders can be investors,
designers, or engineers.
They can also be someone like the user,
or anyone else related to the product.
Second, you should identify or review
any of the use cases for the product.
Next, you should review all
relevant user research.
And finally,
you should review any current designs
that you have on the product.
If you're planning your
first design sprint,
it's likely that you will not
have any current designs.
In that case, you should focus
on these first three tasks
when going about the design sprint.
At Udacity,
we recently planned two design sprints.
The first design challenge involved
redesigning the entire user journey
through a nanodegree from the time the
user hears about a nanodegree, the time
that that user graduates and advances
their career or lands a new job.
A second design sprint focused on one
particular part of our user journey.
We started to think about how to
redesign student support through forms,
code reviews, and other methods.
You'll need to plan a specific
design challenge like these for
your own product, and
it's likely that it will be for
the main user journey, navigation,
and key tasks that users will perform.
The design challenge statement is
what you need to actually write, and
it creates a single focus for
what is the output of the design sprint.
A good challenge statement should
have a couple key qualities.
First, it should be relevant to the
highest priority work of the team, and
it should be tied to a purpose or
key result.
It should also be concise and to
the point, and hopefully inspiring for
yourself.
The design challenge statement should
also include a target audience, or
segments of that audience.
And finally, for
projects that are in progress,
you'll want to include a launch time
stated in terms of years or quarters.
So, would you want to be
launching in Q1, Q2, Q3, or Q4?
Your design challenge statement
will identify the tangible
items that you want to have at
the end of the design sprint.
And at the least,
it should answer one of two questions.
What are you missing
that you need critically?
Or, what is the riskiest decision or
hypothesis that you want
to test with your users?
You can use a gap analysis like this one
to determine what the product is missing
or what's one of the riskier decisions
or hypotheses that you need to test.
This checklist is linked
in the instructor notes.
Here's one example of
a challenge statement.
You might design a mobile app
that helps a visitor plan and
find the most relevant personalized and
exciting activities to do in a city,
keeping in mind that the visitor
only has one day for their visit.
The deliverables in this case would
be to get wireframe sketches for
ideas that would be
implemented in Q3 of 2015.
Your design challenge statement should
be similar, and have components
like the what of the deliverable, the
time frame for when you need it by, and
also a clear user with what they'll be
doing in the application or the product.
Now, the goal for your first sprint
will likely to be to map out
the basics of your new website or
app, including some flows, pages, or
screens, and the basic navigation.
Now that you know about a challenge
statement I'd like you to think about
one for your own design sprint.
What would you create and
for what kind of users, and
by when would you create it and
in order to do what?
Take a minute to think about this and
then write your answer in the box below.
Don't feel like you need to commit to
this one design sprint challenge for
your own design sprint.
You could actually change this
later in your final project.